because how I actually kind of  discovered writing dialogue is I used to  be a be an actor and I'd be in acting  classes and so part of your thing in  acting classes to drum up scenes to do  and I always wanted to do scenes from  movies and stuff and then I didn't have  access to any scripts or anything like  that so I would like go and watch a  movie and then I could remember I have  good memories I'd remember the scene so  I'd go home and write the scene down and  whatever I didn't remember I would just  fill in the blanks myself well little by  little I would just start filling in  more blanks and more blanks and just  kind of go off and do my own things and  add to the scenes that was me first my  first attempt at writing dialogue with  stuff like that